le sport c'est la santé ce week-end la
base régionale de loisirs de saint
quentin organisait la deuxième édition
sentez vous sport c'est vraiment un site
et c'était tout le monde avant une
pratique régulière mais on le le mix
aussi avec avec des conseils sur la
diététique le mix aussi avec une qualité
de vie ou peut d'ailleurs faire des
tests de forme des tests de forme plus
avec la fédération française
d'athlétisme
au programme saut à l'élastique boxe
golf badminton balades en calèche pour
les personnes à mobilité réduite ainsi
qu'une initiation aux gestes qui sauvent
comme j'ai des enfants qui sont en bas
âge c'est l'occasion de découvrir des
sports auxquels ils n'ont pas l'habitude
sans oublier le fil rouge de la journée
la marche nordique avantages de la
marche nordique ce pouvoir mobiliser
l'ensemble du corps tout en ayant une
activité cardio vasculaires similaire à
celle d'un jogging
une fois que les gens maîtrisent bien la
technique d'évasion
l'activité fait de plus en plus
d'adeptes depuis quatre ans tout comme
les rendez vous sentez vous sport 2000
participants sous venus tester leur
forme